[Music]
in mother's love news I love my mother's
love my mom - Tiger gets a lot of us she
used to be a [ __ ] and then she changed
maybe because you changed your piece
mm-hmm
submitted by the year 2038 oh thank you
future that year 2000 I know I was just
trying to adjust it it didn't work
though I don't know what's going on
Conan O'Brien watch Coco oh my god I
can't stand them
oh my god like the funniest [ __ ] no
Brian you need to get out of this circle
well you like Jimmy Fallon the fake
laughter Jay Leno Carson Daly comes also
fake that's why Coco is the [ __ ] but he
comes off hella fake to me when I see
him talk I'm like that's his bed no he's
[ __ ] sarcastically sure I don't know
I love it I [ __ ] love it it yeah he
does he's the most natural one yeah
Jimmy Fallon though this [ __ ] is
like so what project are you working on
Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel's chill what about
the car karaoke time James Gordon James
Corden he's more of like a shows men
like like he wants to be a star he
didn't get to make it in singing so now
he's like getting his seat Coco is just
whenever I see him like come up on like
articles or videos and I see him
interact with people I'm like I don't
like you you just don't like gingers
admit it right there I think so it's a
ginger thing isn't it no it is I thought
making me out to be a racist here we go
our fans are smarter than that they know
you're not racing they know it's a
conspiracy okay a popular Taiwanese
restaurant is described as the product
of an Asian mom who sacrificed
everything for herself that's the very
depressing article
now I can already cry or inspiring
actually I'm sorry that's the more the
inspiring route it's not why is it the
best sake I don't know I just picture
this woman struggling to make like this
pork mince bowl I pictured a stinky tofu
food trucks Oh God
have you guys smelled see you probably
have yeah that [ __ ] is ass it's so
strong do you like it you like it no
there you go how come we thought about
it so much maybe cuz I eat there's just
about there's nothing on this planet
that I would need yeah I look like I'm
really pretty indiscriminate about
whatever give me that thing go but there
aren't things that I like absolutely I'm
excited to eat and that's not one of
them that's like if someone just took a
Dookie and spread their ass cheeks and
you [ __ ] motorboat that buffo [ __ ]
left all over their moustaches [ __ ] I'll
just stick to like salty tofu it's the
same [ __ ] to me actly
reed is fried deep fried tofu sick [ __ ]
I don't thank you basically just regular
tofu right nothing I'm with you I'm down
but it doesn't taste and smell like [ __ ]
I think it's kind of like the asian
massage you know i like asian massage
just feel good because it's a little bit
of pain in it I pick punch you
yeah and then you feel good after that's
the point of the tofu where it tastes
like [ __ ] but it tastes good afterwards
Wow how does your brain work man you
know how like something like the coffee
right it's so [ __ ] bitter that the
aftertaste is sweet
yeah oh it is not no no no but sticky
tofu I agree with the bitter but it
doesn't taste like any body part thing
that's like a excrement okay so this
isn't oh it tastes like pee but you know
what it's all good baby but it's all
good
[Laughter]
Gilbert probably have you guys have
Filipino bug along is fermented bomb
going fried rice it's the best I put it
on everything you put it on rice you
could put it on like a sour mango is it
kind of purple it's purple yeah yeah I
tried it before not sure but you don't
like a little bit right because it's
super strong but if there's even a
cheaper version of it called heap on and
it's like bright pink and that that
shit's pretty strong but I think that
because I started there the graduation
to stinky tofu wasn't that fermented
shrimp a still tastes like shrimp them
it's very intense because they put that
in Vietnamese food like in Boone real
they put that [ __ ] in there yeah oh yeah
but there's a street version of it
that's like a cheaper version that I
think they let for math too long then it
has like hints of [ __ ] yours hint
stinky tofu is actual [ __ ] butthole they
can exclude I thought it tastes like
garlic but that's like saying I grew up
on diapers I still don't want to be on I
wish I couldn't taste stinky tofu the
way Taiwanese to do yeah so I could
enjoy it too I don't want to limit
myself I want more options if I have
more things that make me happy more you
know it's better some perspective but
poop would just don't make me happy I
just cannot do it awesome perspective
yeah so this right here it's about this
mama
her name is mama cow and I pronounced
right I don't have to see me I have to
see the Chinese character I could beat a
yeah Cal Cal yeah cat yo piece we oh
nice a girl fries Taiwanese I'm learning
what is it what do you say you've been
learning we don't have water
no no no ice water but what well yeah
beans we oh yeah I don't know if that
means what I want oh I see you got her
about her Thai what is this [ __ ] it's
all [ __ ] up dude Oh
that was better
morado I don't see you see what I got
the go through he's so mean to me oh I'm
just trying to learn it [ __ ] trying
to connect together yes mam along with
her husband and her three sons they own
this is the family Oh her jeans are
strong yeah yeah that [ __ ] looks like a
racist cartoon making fun of them songs
my even for me I probably call him a
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy they made a
really funny joke and then they captured
that moment yeah no but they're racist
on themselves alright you look like when
you [ __ ] smile yes I look like that
like in real life to smile people don't
even know my eyes are [ __ ] open the
data kind of looks like weight like
Bobby right now he dies a little bit
what you want looks like that thank God
I thought you were gonna say the mom to
be the least cute one which one's the
middle my dad is definitely a hottie the
middle the end to my body
Bobby's gonna license that you better
say that [ __ ] know so they own this
shop Oh
chop chop in Toronto hipster has a
mother [ __ ] that's cool yeah so 20 years
ago the mom she was treated to some
dumplings by her brother-in-law in
Taiwan before she immigrated to Canada
and so her brother-in-law was like you
know you should learn how to make this
in case you get homesick when you're
over there so she was like oh you mean
it's so easy like it was just really
easy so she store the dent I find recipe
I love Taiwanese dumpling yeah they bomb
they're really going to detail into how
like she they decided to open the
restaurant restaurant because they also
mentioned that she owns a hair salon so
she
this mama's a hustler she's had that
hair salon since she immigrated to
Toronto and like she's just talking
about how she runs on very little sleep
because she'd rather work hard live a
simple life Asian to her her family has
been me because this full month yeah cuz
her oldest son he's really into cooking
so he's the cook of that restaurant so
that's Todd it was really important to
her to make sure like her sons are into
their passions as well oh wow yeah so
this is some of the food that they serve
her son cooks there yeah he's a that's
his like dream yeah that's badass so she
passes down the like family heirloom
recipes and he [ __ ] does it and then
she has another son that works in
advertising how come all the marketing
issues he has like a day job and then
after he finishes that marketing
advertising job then he'll clock into
the restaurant and help out that looks
like some traditional ass [ __ ] though
yeah it's delicious pancake that's my
[ __ ]
you know what this is what was that I
don't know what that was all about is
the porthole just about oh yeah yeah
yeah I'm happy that people still do
family businesses
yeah and it's in Toronto Gobert nine
bucks six bucks
my friend she does family business and
all of the family members they go to
college and they come back and help the
family with their newfound knowledge
that's all yeah I always wanted to do
that because my dad was like we're gonna
open up a restaurant but then like he
can't follow through on [ __ ] and then so
we never did I had dreams baby and I
think that's why we got it to the
restaurant yeah your dad was a musician
yeah but then he had to have a side gate
cuz he always sucked with like money and
stuff so he was like always thinking
about the next hustle while he's doing
his music [ __ ] was he a cut he could
grill he could cook that's why I get my
cooking from you know the funny thing is
just pointed out like all the guys of JK
cook and all the girlfriends does [ __ ]
none of the girls in our group cook yeah
who cooks between you and Bobby
Oh interests Bobby looks like he
couldn't cook the save his life man yeah
I cook my girl doesn't cook no just no I
dislike that very
I think it's cuz all that dudes and JK
are artists so it's just another medium
that's true but you know what the you
know just as a me know cleaner like she
could clean like a [ __ ] I can't
clean like you mean like she's mean at
cleaning
she's mean about it she's good like
she's so good that I let her take
control when it comes to the cleaning I
just shut the [ __ ] up tell me what to do
you know what I thought about the other
day - I think Mariel only said she can't
cook so I cook I think she's [ __ ]
around with me at this point you know
she's not my [ __ ] passion needs to
feed himself yeah you know what it is no
I feel like sometimes because like she'd
be making some [ __ ] I'm like no humans
gonna eat that why would you even create
that [ __ ] look it's yummy
you know I did that on purpose that's
what I'm saying like it literally
clicked the other day I was like who the
[ __ ] puts all this garbage and [ __ ]
soft tofu in this [ __ ] like it's like
bomb she mmm so good I've never seen you
swallow it though so I should watch it
through completion next time so I'm
pretty sure she's going like this like
yo my visual it's probably googling how
to make prisoner slop yep what the [ __ ]
does she make like stinky tofu acai bowl
right by for example I'm like yo let's
just have like a morning smoothie right
so what would you do get some [ __ ]
milk fruits whatever some [ __ ] right
she it's like tofu she throws a bunch of
kale in there some flaxseed and then
some grass and there's some dirt and
some rocks all of those made sense - the
rock yeah but there's a way to make
those shakes taste good but she doesn't
specifically to make it as bitter as
possible there's no food shakes
I never heard at all never heard of it
I'm good off that [ __ ] dude I like total
ice cream I gotta show you guys when
Bobby tried to make guacamole last week
I saw how he cut the avocado he
what animal cuddle me cut the avocado
you know he's supposed to cut it
lengthwise remove the speed he cut it
zip through the scene you cut the actual
seat yeah cut it this way yeah but the
taha like the other way through the seat
like he sawed through the seat oh can I
tell you when I saw that that she gave
me anxiety
that's like somebody who [ __ ] cuts a
cake and they just took a square out of
nowhere in the middle of it no I will
[ __ ] murder you what are you doing
see did you think that that's part of a
boy I don't know what he made and he
obviously blamed everything on me he's
like well you weren't you weren't here
so that's what happened avocados this
way you know we cut it this way he could
it this way you just see the top of the
seed yeah crazy that's awesome
[Music]